what we're gonna do is we're gonna move
a bit further into the exercise I'm
gonna do one of these later questions
because you sort of need to see it'll
help you a lot if I show you how they
work
but I don't wanna do that the beginning
because your brains would explode
and also I want to just quickly have a
look at this one this is I think
question three this is the key check for
me did I get the numbers right yeah okay
great now when you have a look at
question three they say hey here's a
polynomial can you work out the
remainder like that's we're using the
remainder theorem when you divide by and
then they give you something a little
bit different they give you I think for
a memory it's 2x minus 1 now this is a
bit sneaky because it's not in the
format that we were expecting we know if
you were dividing by X plus 5 then
what's the a you're gonna put in for
this guy it'd be negative 5 feel like I
know to do with this but with this
you're like there's a number at the
front there's an extra coefficient so
what are we gonna do and importantly not
just what are we gonna do but why that's
actually the main thing that I want to
know okay so some of you've already
given this a go what's your instinct for
what you should put in you should put in
a half okay now my question to you is
but but why is it just because I can say
if I divide this by 2 I get this like
can I just divide by 2 just because I
want to now you can actually just divide
by 2 but I'm going to show you why if I
went through and divided by 2 X minus 1
right I'm gonna write this just like I
did before this is my dividend here's my
divisor now I haven't actually done the
division so I don't know what the
quotient will be right and then
presumably after this I will get some
kind of remainder okay
now have a look right when I think about
what's the a that I want to put into
this remember the original thing was I
can put a in here because it makes this
guy become 0 and it's like cool that's
why it just makes the whole thing
disappear leaving the remainder behind
now I just asked the same question while
this guy what's the value of x that I
put in to make this collapse and
disappear and leave only the remainder
and the answer is it's the thing which
makes this thing zero right when is 2 X
minus 1 equal to 0 and the answer is
it's when X is equal to
or half so it's not just because you're
magically dividing by two and therefore
you know you can't just say oh I don't
like I don't like this fraction I'm just
gonna divide this by two and I just get
three right like you can't just divide
by two because you want to we can divide
by two because it makes sense with how
we did this in the first place I want
this thing to go to zero so taking half
of that will do that okay so that was
the question someone asked me before can
I ask you now to flirt your eyes down
all the way to question twelve question
twelve is a little more complicated so
it looks messy I know but we're gonna do
this together and I promise you know all
the things you need to do to do this but
let's walk through it together okay so
here's how it starts you'll need your
pen your hand for this by the way okay
so they give you a polynomial 2x cubed
minus x squared plus 8x plus B can you
write that down with me this is our
polynomial P of X and we're just going
to write it down exactly as it appears
2x cubed minus x squared plus ax plus B
then they tell you a bunch of things
from this and there's a lot of
information we want to sort of chew at
it slowly
right the first thing they say is it has
a remainder of 16 or division by X minus
1 what does that mean okay so the thing
that we're dividing by the divisor this
guy here for that first phrase the
divisor is going to be X minus 1 right
so when you divide by X minus 1 what
that gives you is a remainder of what
did they say again 16 okay now this is
like a weird awkward way of just saying
without words
it's just symbols but I can make a
statement using the remainder theorem
that takes this information makes it a
bit more concise right what would be the
value of a that I put in to my
polynomial it's gonna be 1 right he's my
ex - hey so I can say P of 1 is gonna be
that made of 16 right so this is what I
get out of the remainder theorem when I
interpret the information they've given
me they do it again there's another
divisor and another remainder what is it
what's the divisor X
x + 2 x + 2 so if i divide by x + 2
what's the a that goes with x + 2 the a
the part that I'm actually gonna input
is negative - yeah and then that gives
you a remainder which is I don't even
know - 17 okay very good
now jot this down with me right I've
used the remainder theorem I've used it
twice the question I think says that's
the remainder that's just me trying to
read the question what's the actual
question where they actually asking find
the value of these guys a and B that's
what we're after
okay so how do I take this and get to
these guys well P of 1 is shorthand it's
just an abbreviation for this thing
instead of writing X I'm gonna write 1
right so let's go ahead and let's do
that if I take everything up here and
replace all the X's with ones
I'll get this 2 times 1 cubed yeah I'm
putting in 1 right
- 1 squared + what a times 1 plus B oops
I don't need it back a millionaire okay
so this is P of 1 of successfully
replaced all my X's with ones but I know
from the question that that's equal to
something it's equal to 16 see that so
this complicated Miss I can simplify a
whole lot right to take away 1 is just 1
so I've got 1 plus a plus B equals 16 so
a plus B I can subtract 1 from both
sides which gives me 15 now hold that
thought see how I got that from this
statement I can do something identical
but from this statement so I've got to
replace all my X's negatives let's give
it a go yeah exactly
you're kind of like four lines in front
of me - lots of negative 2 cubed - I'm
substituting in negative 2 what's the
next thing I'm gonna write
negative two squared plus a lots of
negative two plus B apparently when I do
that it should be equal to negative 17
this is a little bit Messier cuz you're
like ah gross but I can still do it okay
um where we go this negative 60 very
good yeah that negative is also being
squared
there's minus signs right the Devils in
the details minus 4 minus 2 a plus B
equals negative 17 and now before I do
that I could probably collect like terms
that might make it easier that's
negative 20 and now I'm gonna add 20 to
both sides which gives me the 3 on the
other side okay so now I'm like oh I
have an equation here with A's and B's
and I've got another one with A's and
B's oh you have been experiencing right
so much of our mathematical skill and
knowledge is about taking a problem that
looks gross you're like what I do with
this and then translating it through
something you've learned into a problem
you're like I can do this in like two
minutes with my hands tied behind my
back I will let you guys go ahead and
work out you can do simultaneous
equations usually by one of two methods
substitution or elimination which do you
feel like be more helpful the
elimination is gonna be easier cuz
you've got a plus B and a plus B there
I'm gonna let you guys finish that
question on your own you'll find out
what a and B are yeah okay so hope that
makes sense I'll leave that there in
case you didn't write any notes down so
you can catch up and see if you can try
your hand at